we're at the cusp of a longevity
revolution biology has become an
engineering project just like computer
programs have ones and zeros the human
body has a code to it's made up of the
AC T and G of DNA and scientists are
learning how to reverse engineer that
things like tissue engineering gene
therapy and other types of personalized
medicine that are going to allow people
to live longer and healthier lives
there's only ever been one person in the
world who's ever been cured of AIDS and
that's Timothy brown and he was cured
because he got a bone marrow transplant
from somebody who had a genetic mutation
that that doesn't allow aids to
proliferate in the body and so
researchers are now working on how they
can create that genetic tweak in other
people who have AIDS so that they can
curate gene therapy for for the last
decade has had trouble because if not it
wasn't easy to do before researchers
have made a lot of progress in making it
safer and and easier to do dr. Carl June
at the University of Pennsylvania has
been working on making the tweaks to t
cells to try to cure AIDS he actually
just had a really exciting announcement
recently where he used gene therapy to
cure leukemia what he did was he took
out some of the immune cells from the
cancer patients tweaked them the t-cells
he tweaked them so that they would
notice cancer as an infection because
the problem with cancer is that your
body doesn't realize it's in a foreign
invader because it's part of your system
and it doesn't attack it and so what dr.
June did was he tweaked the immune cells
of these patients so that they would
notice the cancer then rhian out in any
did that in the lab then he rejected
them into the patients and the patients
got huge fevers and reacted essentially
as if they had a big infection and after
a couple of weeks all of their cancer
was gone because their immune systems
had had fought it off and so that's one
example of how scientists might be able
to recode are
systems to fight off diseases sometimes
it can take a long time to go from the
lab to widespread use in society for
instance tissue engineering is already
here I mean scientists have the ability
to grow brand new human organs like
tracheas and bladders and blood vessels
in the lab it can be done with your own
adult stem cells it's not in widespread
use right now and how long will that
take you know that that's up to the
regulators and and not only that but
wreaths and training doctors to learn
how to use these techniques and so it
does actually take take a long time
there are so many advances going on
right now in biotechnology that are
really really have a WOW factor right
like gene therapy to cure cancer and
tissue engineering growing brand new
tracheas in the lab also to cure cancer
or to cure damage from infections I mean
all these things that are going on and
you see them once in the newspaper and
you read it and you say oh that's great
and then you forget about it but if you
look around and you take all of those
stories and you put them together as as
I did and one in one big chapter you can
see a real clear picture of how the
future is going to change